how many million dollar contributions
have you had tonight
uh i haven't had not one of those you
got one now buddy
oh yes sir we gotta we got a million
over here
we gotta we got a million we got a
million from mr john
texas native nfl wide receiver dez
bryant helped raise more than two
million dollars for harvey victims last
night at a t stadium in dallas the man
on the other end of the phone line of
course was dallas cowboys owner jerry
jones
jones pledged one million dollars the
cowboys held a telethon after their game
against the houston texas was canceled
families have lost their home so
i really just hope
you know they can see that we're here
for them and wants we want them to be
back on their feet as soon as possible
brian himself has donated 50 thousand
dollars to relief efforts thank you mr
bryant mr jones those are just some of
the donations pouring in from across the
country to the flood victims the white
house says that president trump is
pledging a million dollars of his
personal funds to the recovery effort
celebrities and businesses are also
stepping up houston's texan star that's
j.j wattus raised more than 13 million
dollars for the city through crowd
funding and he only wanted to raise 200
000 at the beginning he put in 100
thousand dollars to kick it off so go jj
walmart will donate up to 20 million
dollars including up to 10 million for
red cross shelters but many americans
have many questions about which
organizations will provide the most help
there are also concerns about charity
scams fortunes digital editor andrew
nusca is here and andrew good morning
good morning everybody wants to help all
kinds of charities are popping up online
you're getting emails how do you know
who's who what's what and who's legit
it's impossible to tell us what do you
do right
the options are overwhelming right well
you could go national or you could go
local that's the first place to start
right so national you've got great
organizations working in in houston
americaires you got heart to heart you
got united way i really like team
rubicon they send in military veterans
very cool um but then there are also
these local uh options right you didn't
mention the red cross in the national
organization that's true that on purpose
no but they are they are there but
everybody knows the red cross right i
want to highlight some of the ones that
uh that people don't know as well the um
the local ones though of course who's
going to know those but they're really
really important and they're they're
really plugged in on the ground so
you've got certainly the city's relief
fund right that the mayor's uh set up
you've got uh i really like the the
texas diaper bank they make sure that
diapers go to displaced children and
you've got feeding texas of course
people need food what's great about the
local ones is that they're going to be
there months years after this uh tragic
event is over because they are there and
that's part of their job as opposed to
the national ones who come in and then
they have other priorities well that's
the tough thing about you know the red
cross and other organizations like they
cover all of these kinds of disasters
and if you give to them yeah it's going
to be used
for one of those purposes but it might
not actually go to houston right so if
you want to get your money there
definitely go for a local do you prefer
local over national in general i i like
that they're focused right these are
smaller organizations they don't have
huge marketing budgets they can't really
afford to be calling out and working on
the ground at the same time so i think
they're the ones who need the help you
also say to do research because there's
administrative costs that these folks
have to uh have to spend on and you want
to keep those numbers down that's right
that's research this how do you find out
well look uh i it's silly as it sounds
it's like just the same as buying a
vacuum cleaner right you got to do your
homework so you got to look and and and
take a look at the reviews and figure
out if the organizations that you're
looking for uh uh
you know you can vouch for them right so
the better business bureau great reviews
there there's a company called charity
watch that makes sure to review those
organizations all great choices and
people always want to send stuff andrew
you don't seem to be a fan of sending
stuff we look at it on the video and
there's piles of things and i often
wonder how are they going to sort
through that and how are they going to
distribute it you don't like sending
stuff why no well when you talk to first
responders they go it's really nice that
america wants to send us their stuff but
one we can't really deal with it and two
we can't get it where we need it most
you know so what i've been uh encouraged
by is of course sending money is the
best not cash but just funds then they
can use them as they want and then
there's also been this uh more
interesting thing recently with
wishlists you know amazon wishlist for
your own gifts well some organizations
have partnered with the company to
basically say here's what we need like a
wedding registry i like that stay off
the cash kind of obvious as to why right
right right don't stuff money in
envelopes probably not a great way it's
also not good for your taxes okay all
right andrew let's go very glad to have
you at the table